i'd like to share with you the top
remedies for the cardiovascular system
so let's cover all the different
potential problems with the heart and
give you an alternative now just so you
know anything that i say is not meant to
replace your medical care check with
your doctor before implementing any of
this information now that being said the
first thing we're going to talk about is
the fuel for the heart the heart
primarily runs on either glucose or
fatty acids
small amount of ketones lactic acid
maybe a little bit of amino acid so the
more the heart is damaged the more
difficulty the heart's going to be able
to access energy from glucose and fatty
acids and this is why ketones can bypass
that damage mechanism and feed the heart
directly this is why i recommend you go
on a ketogenic plan okay so
um it's gonna really help your heart one
of the biggest symptoms of a failing
heart is
fatigue especially upon exertion like
exercise or even going up a flight of
stairs
if you do the ketogenic diet you're
going to find that fatigue goes away
pretty quick
let's first start out with a clot now
the medical treatment for a clot could
be some medication like warfarin which
blocks vitamin k1 and so then you're
going to
not clot as much but there are some
natural things that are out there that
you should investigate number one
something called nato kinase
this is from nato which is fermented
soybeans and natokinase is an enzyme
that can help dissolve clots it prevents
thrombosis okay
so it's
anti-thrombotic so nato kinase is one
remedy and then garlic so garlic has
anti-clotting factors okay
now there's other natural things but
these are my two favorites all right
next is plaquing
now with a plaque
the first thing you have is some type of
damage to the vessel of the heart
usually because there's too much
oxidation or inflammation and then you
have this chain reaction that occurs
with the body forming a band-aid out of
cholesterol
protein
and calcium okay and so the best thing
to do for clots is to
do something that would have prevented
the problem in the first place which is
a powerful antioxidant called
tocotrienols this is a type of vitamin e
that i like better than the tocopherol
because tocatrinos works like 50 times
stronger than a tocopherol and so it's a
really good antioxidant
for the heart especially and it also
can help you if you have angina because
it allows the heart muscle to get more
oxygen capacity so angina is chest pain
so when the heart cramps you need more
oxygen
so with plaque tocotrinols there is some
great data on tocotrinols helping to
dissolve
fibrosis now i'm not going to say that
that's going to help you in your
situation but
there is some data out there now vitamin
k2 can help you with calcium buildup
because k2 helps to direct calcium into
the bone so if you're getting a buildup
of calcium in the wrong places whether
it's the joint or the artery
k2 is an important vitamin
and it works together with vitamin d3
and then vitamin c and i'm not talking
about the synthetic version i'm talking
about consuming a lot of foods with
vitamin c or a food-based vitamin c is a
very good antioxidant to protect the
inside of the arteries all right let's
talk about cholesterol
and i'm not just talking about
cholesterol i'm talking about
a bad lipid profile where you have high
triglycerides maybe you have high levels
of the wrong type of ldl and your ratios
are not good a really good remedy for
all cholesterol problems would be niacin
you don't want to get the non-flush
niacin you want to get straight niacin
and niacin is a b3 vitamin
that can
help you
balance out the cholesterol ratios and
give you more hdl to ldl and etc and
niacin helps convert cholesterol to bile
salts okay and so this next remedy
called tutka is a type of bile salt that
also helps transport cholesterol out of
the body
angina which is chest pain that could
come from
a clogged artery or if the arteries are
clear it could be a problem with the
heart muscle itself and so tocotrinols
is what i recommend and also coenzyme
q10 which is a very powerful antioxidant
for the mitochondria
especially for the heart so when people
take statin drugs like lipitor lipitor
depletes coenzyme q10 the very thing
that you need for the heart muscle so
people take statins for high cholesterol
but what about the heart muscle itself
right we need to support that coenzyme
q10 is really good for people with heart
damage and people that are aging
just to give you that extra energy for
the heart muscle itself and it works
within the mitochondria okay high blood
pressure the top two things that i
recommend for that would be high levels
of potassium because potassium helps
keep the arteries
elastic preventing
stiffness
potassium also acts as a diuretic if
you're retaining fluid because you're on
a high carb diet and by the way certain
diuretics cause the loss of potassium so
instead of focusing on lowering your
sodium if you increase your potassium
you can help lower blood pressure and
protect the heart
because there's some really interesting
data
that you really need to know about
relating to sodium and i will put that
link down below
because if your sodium is too low that
can actually create more problems with
not just the heart but other parts of
the body and then vitamin d okay vitamin
d deficiency can create high blood
pressure so these two are very important
in regulating blood pressure okay
homocysteine is an indicator that there
is
heart damage or there's going to be
heart damage maybe one problem would be
in a large heart okay
and so
if you have high homocysteine levels you
need more b vitamins okay nutritional
yeast is a really good source and just
so you know the primary reason why
people have a b vitamin deficiency is
because they're consuming too many
refined grains and even sugar so
nutritional yeast is a very key thing to
keep your homocysteine levels low
now if someone does have cardiomegaly or
in a large heart
b12 is a really good antidote and also
making sure that you don't have too much
iron okay
and then tutka tutka is a type of bile
salt that can help you against
an enlarged heart and also just heart
muscle damage in general
a murmur can come from many different
sources but if the heart is enlarged
guess what the valves are not going to
fit anymore and that can cause a murmur
so
the b vitamins again are
a good remedy for murmurs and then we
have a high pulse rate if your pulse
rate is too high usually you're you're
too low in potassium because you're on a
high carb diet which actually depletes
potassium so more potassium can help
lower the pulse rate now by the way if
you have
low blood pressure you probably need
more sodium okay more sea salt
or it could be that you need more
adrenal support
arrhythmias that could range anywhere
from atrial fibrillation to just
different arrhythmias to
palpitations
your electrolytes are off you need more
potassium magnesium
tatka which is that unique type of bile
salt that i mentioned can also help with
arrhythmias
one side note with arrhythmias that you
need to know
electromagnetic fields from your cell
phones let's say you have your cell
phone in your pocket next your heart or
your
in front of your computer all day or
like me
i had the entire
back of my wall where i slept my bedroom
uh had these wires that were
crossed somehow i had all sorts of high
levels of electromagnetic fields that i
was bathing in every night when i would
sleep that was affecting my the rhythm
of my heart i got that corrected with an
electrician
and my arrhythmias went away and one
interesting point about this arrhythmias
let's say you're an athlete and you're a
bike rider and you do a lot of exercise
and you do like a sustained type of
uh exercise at a high level for a long
period of time what happens the heart
becomes so strong
it can throw off the electrical activity
of the heart and so it's not a
pathological reason for arrhythmia but
it is a cause of arrhythmias that i did
a video on so i will put that link down
below as well all right so that's some
great data for the heart
the other thing that i think you should
watch would be relating to sodium okay
the dangers of low sodium check it out i
put it right here
you